welcome w bri ry breathe okay from
canada so let's do let's do the ROI
again with black okay playing it
differently now I'm going with g6 base
set up this as possible after White has
played that very early d3 which is not
bad or anything just very early
commitment and okay can i prepare a 5
voice that crazy probably is crazier
okay that shouldn't be too bad here
let's have a look here should be 64
traits and I'm not sure that I want the
double bond I think I can prepare that
tween did talking at seven okay this one
that should be ok right if I take here
and it's very equal ish this position
yeah I can take that pawn now or not
Bishop age sex is this dangerous maybe
can also go d5 if that was my
alternative and not a bad one
yeah I'm ready for the temple game here
they come and yeah I want the night on
your six not the Queen just wonder what
the best way is to do that let's start
with this move
that shouldn't be too bad feels fairly
solid and the night settles on on e6
it's difficult to ever to get c5 really
played an eyelid let's prevent age 5 not
sure about this movie Aquino 5 or that's
nice like that this is nice that's nice
for black I think f5 even know nobody
more please you might not take cakes
Bishop takes d4 is really weak yeah so
did he study calculate something here if
I take here on before Bishop takes
Knight takes rook as a checked the thing
is my idea was to just drop back and ask
him about that week pawn them d for it's
just very very weak
Bishop g5 this 95 he really has no
square G goucher and now I'm threatening
94 let F was also strong and will win
this pawn perhaps writer for takes rupee
one King you want to get for VI wins
upon come on let's do it yay white
resigns yeah because of that but that
was already lost position yeah I think
he made a couple of mistakes here with
the Queen the Queen trade is very very
helpful for me definitely I think after
that I don't have much to fear well this
position still felt like white might
have something because of more space I
felt I'm okay but definitely not better
but after the Queen trade and no this is
definitely wrong now i get f 6 or f5 and
i just have the better structure and he
definitely has to and be quick now and
reorganizing yeah after that it gets
gets very very serious the computer
wants to do this this and just stay ever
black it's just in fantastic shape he IM
got more space this is a week porn and
the only one who can do something is me
I've got this safely blockaded him with
the night this is weak it's better for
black by some degree but it's it's less
than this I mean here I really felt like
this should be excellent t4s just week
44 without any compensation I wonder why
the computer is still so relaxed here f3
here king of one and it says that
is equal don't get it or has said equal
if i go here Jack do the same thing as
in the game why I said equal I rookie to
he Dwight has countered flame okay so
it's not that easy maybe I have to go
this to this first this is the computer
line g3 me okay this is this is kind of
still holding on because this is also
weakness yeah okay agreed like it's
better but it's not that much well now
it gets kind of serious this is this is
chan yeah that this is actually not
clear amazing wise f3 root g43 and this
is dangerous or miss counterplay where
an estimated that I will think I thought
I was just winning him it's just a bit
too much I like like one move I can get
this and prevent any entries then it's
easy so I can be happy that he actually
poof yeah it just give me that night
give me that night okay well thanks for
watching